Carmela initially asked me for money
back in 2019 and I said No and then she
just kind of was like okay and kind of
ignored me
until March 2020 she messaged me that's
when I kind of like let my guard down
and send her something
I think between 50 to 100 a month
you know she doesn't really question the
amount I give her but she just like
is always asking for more
I just like
like my emotions are like all over the
place
it's like you can like feel it but then
it's like it still doesn't feel real
it's like
I don't know
it's weird
[Music]
I messaged her for them
uh you know I told her you lied to me
you tricked me and I put babe How Could
you um they told me that you were a man
that she read it
no it was not even opened
like messaging a ghost
I'm going back to
all the past where she like said I love
you and it's weird but I still kind of
feel like maybe
she's real or something but then I know
the person that the picture is real but
like
I had connection with the actual person
so I still feel that connection
like I still have like a glimmer of hope
that
maybe it was just someone else who had
her phone or something maybe she was
hacked I don't know
no matter how messed up the situation is
I'm not ready to walk away from Carmella
yet
because I still have you know a little
bit of me that says
this might all just be a
misunderstanding
I want to get to the Bottom of
Everything
I'm just gonna not message her no more
today and then then tomorrow I'm going
to wake up and be like was that a dream
it's actually a nightmare so that's what
I'm afraid of the most like
how I'm going to feel tomorrow
foreign